The art museums were closed
for six years of my presidency
for a major
restoration that would
make them an appropriate
place in which to locate art.
They didn't have appropriate air
handling and climate control,
and a number of other
dimensions of the building
required really
careful attention.
But the Calderwood
Courtyard was there
as a kind of center
of the building
even before the renovation.
It was carefully
preserved through what
was a gut overhaul
of the building,
and now restored in
a newly glorious form
with Renzo Piano's lantern
above it, the opening to the sky
that he installed on
the top of the building.
So light streams down
into the courtyard,
and it is your entryway
into the museum.
It's a place where you
can go and sit at a table
and have a cup of coffee
from the coffee shop
that has opened in the
newly renovated museum.
It's a place you can linger
in between adventures
into various galleries
in the museum.
But it's also become a kind
of public square for Harvard
in a way, as we have
many events there.
The dinner after the awarding
of the Du Bois medals each fall
takes place there.
I remember greeting a group
of middle school students
who had come from a distressed
area of New York City
to be introduced to Harvard
and introduced to what college
might be, and I had the
privilege of welcoming them
as they stood in that hallway.
And it's a place where
many events and gatherings
take place.
But it's also an entry into
the museum and an entry
into the restoration
of art to the center
of our lives with the newly
renovated Harvard University
Art Museums Building.